♪ ♪
>> Jesse: CONGRESS IS SOUNDING
THE ALARM ON THE FAILED COVID-19
RESPONSE, AND IT’S TROUBLING
TIES TO CHINA.
THE AGENCY BATTLE DIRECTORS
COMING UNDER MAJOR FIRE FACING
NEW PRESSURE FROM LAWMAKERS TO
TEST TESTIFIED BEFORE CONGRESS
AND EXPLAIN HIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNIST REGIME.
PREVIOUSLY PRAISING CHINA’S
TRANSPARENCY.
DESPITE BEIJING’S ATTEMPT TO
COVER UP THE CRISIS.
HERE IS PRESIDENT TRUMP ON HIS
START TO CUT THE FUNDING.
>> OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
PAYING THEM FROM 300-500, AND
EVEN MORE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
CHINA HAS BEEN PAYING THEM LESS
THAN 40, AND THEY ARE VERY, VERY
VERY, CHINA-CENTRIC AS I SAID
DURING THE WEEKS.
CHINA ALWAYS SEEMS TO GET THE
BETTER OF THE ARGUMENT, AND I
DON’T LIKE THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
THAT NEXT WEEK IN GREAT DETAIL.
WE ARE LOOKING AT IT VERY, VERY
CLOSELY.
>> Jesse: ONE OF THE THINGS I
FOUND OUT ABOUT CHINA AND
ETHIOPIA, THE COUNTRY WHERE
DR. TATRO’S COMES FROM, CHINA
HAS GROOMED THE SKY AND GROOMING
ETHIOPIA LIKE A POWER DYNAMIC
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS.
BILLION-DOLLAR TRADE,
BILLION-DOLLAR INVESTMENTS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ALL SORTS OF
DEALS, AND THEY REALLY WINE AND
DINE THIS GUY.
HE WAS THEIR TOP PICK.
AMERICA DID NOT WANT THIS GUY.
HE WAS THERE...
TOPIC, THEY GOT HIM
AND IT PAID OFF.
>> Dana: YOU’RE ABOUT TO HEAR
THE TRAIN, BY THE WAY.
JUST SO YOU KNOW, IT’S NOT MY
STOMACH.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY GO AROUND THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE OF
CHINA’S AGGRESSIVE INVESTMENTS
INTO THIS INITIATIVE, YOU CAN
FIND ALL PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD
WHO ARE BASICALLY IN CHINA’S
BACK POCKET.
NOW DR. TENDRILS HAD BEEN
PRAISED IN THE PAST BY SOMEBODY
LIKE DR. FAUCI, SO THEY HAVE
KNOWN EACH OTHER FOR YEARS,
MAYBE THERE IS NOT ALLOWED TO
SEE HERE, BUT IT IS SUSPICIOUS,
AND ESPECIALLY BECAUSE HE LOOKED
BACK TO THOSE CHOLERA EPIDEMICS
THAT YOU MENTIONED THE OTHER
DAY, JUST SEE THAT HAPPEN IN
ETHIOPIA, AND THERE ARE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
A FRIEND OF MINE WHO IS FORMER
INTELLIGENCE TOLD ME THAT HE IS
SUPER SUSPICIOUS OF ALL OF THIS.
I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT IS A
LITTLE BIT LIKE THE BOSS WHO
CALLS YOU ON A FRIDAY AND SAYS,
MAKE SURE THAT YOU COME TO MY
OFFICE AT 10:00 A.M. MONDAY, I
HAVE SOMETHING IMPORTANT TO TALK
ABOUT AND THEN YOU WORRY ABOUT
IT ALL WEEKEND.
BECAUSE WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID
RIGHT BEFORE THE CLIP IS HE
SHOWED UP, WE ARE THINKING ABOUT
THIS, AND NEXT WEEK WE WILL MAKE
AN ANNOUNCEMENT.
AND NEXT WEEK WE WILL TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO DO WITH THE
FUNDING FOR THE W.H.O.
AND YOU JUST KNOW THAT THAT IS
GOING TO RUIN THEIR WEEKEND.
AND THEY WILL BE WORRIED ABOUT
IT ALL WEEK.
HERE’S ONE THING I WOULD
RECOMMEND.
I THINK THEY LOOK AT A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC AND YOU REALIZE THAT IT
IS SUPER IMPORTANT TO HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE THE HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SO THAT THEY ARE
ALL COMMUNICATING WITH EACH
OTHER.
AND WE CAN’T JUST BE INVOLVED
WITH THE MONEY, WE HAVE TO HAVE
A MUCH MORE HEAVY HAND
INVOLVEMENT WITH WESTERN SOCIETY
AND THE UNITED STATES.
SO I WOULD NOT NECESSARILY CUT
BACK THE FUNDING.
I WOULD PUSH AHEAD AND MAKE SURE
THE UNITED STATES HAS MORE
INFLUENCE.
>> Jesse: JUAN, WHAT WOULD YOU
DO?
THE WH OH IS SAYING THAT THEY
WERE NOT SCIENTIFIC.
THAT MASKS DON’T WORK, TRAVEL
BANDS DON’T WORK.
THEY ARE THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> Juan: I THINK FIRST OF ALL
YOU DON’T WANT TO POLITICIZE A
PANDEMIC.
AND I THINK W.H.O. PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE AS WE ARE TRYING
TO GET AN INTERNATIONAL
COOPERATION IN DEALING WITH
THIS.
WE CAN’T STOP IT IN ONE CORNER
AND PRETEND OH, IT IS OVER
BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE IT ALL OVER
THE WORLD, YOU HAVE TO DEAL WITH
IT ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THAT’S WHY YOU NEED A WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
I DO THINK THAT CHINA TOLD LIES.
AND IN SOME CASES THEY LIED TO
THE W.H.O., AND THE W.H.O.
ECHOED THOSE LIVES.
TO DO I BLAME THE W.H.O., TO
SOME EXTENT, YES, BUT MOST OF
ALL I BLAME CHINA.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE W.H.O.
AND THE ROLE THEY HAVE
PERFORMED, I THINK THE USE OF
MASKS, EVEN OUR EXPERTS HAVE
CHANGED THEIR POSITION ON IT.
BUT THE W.H.O. SAID VERY CLEARLY
WHEN THEY DECLARED THAT THERE
WAS A GLOBAL PANDEMIC, IN THIS
COUNTRY, OUR PRESIDENT WAS
SAYING, WE CAN HANDLE THIS, WE
GOT THIS UNDER CONTROL.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE IS ALL
FINGER-POINTING AND BLAME, AS I
SAID ON OTHER TOPICS.
I’M NOT SURE THAT THIS IS
HELPFUL AS WE TRY TO COME TO
TERMS WITH THINGS.
IN THE POLITICAL ARENA, I THINK
THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
POINT FINGERS AND BLAME THE
W.H.O.
I THINK THEY SHOULD MAY BE
COMING YOU KNOW WHAT, GO AFTER
CHINA IF YOU WANT TO.
CHINA HAS SO MUCH OF OUR DEBT
AND CONTROL SO MUCH OF OUR
MANUFACTURING, TAKE A LOOK AT
YOUR iPHONE.
IT’S HARD TO GO AFTER CHINA.
IT MIGHT BE EASIER TO PICK ON
THE W.H.O.
THIS IS NOT THE RIGHT TIME TO DO
IT.
>> Jesse: BOTH ARE CULPABLE,
BUT I AGREE THAT CHINA IS MORE
CULPABLE.
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM AGREES.
LET’S PLAY LINDSAY, AND THEN HE
CAN REACT.
SPEAK OF THE FIRST THING I WANT
TO DO IS GET THE UNITED STATES
SENATE ON THE RECORD THAT WE DO
NOT BLAME TRUMP, WE BLAME CHINA.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR 16,000 AMERICAN
DEATHS, AND 70 MILLION AMERICANS
BEING UNEMPLOYED.
IT IS THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT AND
THE WAY THEY BEHAVED THAT LED TO
THIS PANDEMIC.
>> Greg: I’M NOT INTERESTED
THAT MUCH IN THE BLAME
COMPONENT.
I’M INTERESTED IN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CHINA AND
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
AND HOW WE CAN MODIFY IT SO THAT
IT SERVES OUR NEEDS.
WE KNOW THAT ESSENTIALLY CHINA
IS LIKE A BIG BUSINESS, AND THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION IS
THERE PRESS OFFICE.
SO THEY ARE THE PUBLIC RELATION
FLACKS WHO SMOOTHED OVER THE OIL
SPILL OR THE ACCIDENTAL FOOD
POISONING, OR THE ESCAPED VIRUS,
RIGHT?
THEY ARE THE CATASTROPHIC PUBLIC
RELATIONS AGENCIES THAT ARE
WORKING ON BEHALF OF CHINA.
WE HAVE NO REASON TO DOUBT WHAT
THEY WERE DOING, BECAUSE THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
ANYTHING WITH THE WORLD AS A
PREFIX HAS TO BE GOOD, RIGHT?
WORLD MUSIC, CAN’T STAND IT.
SO THE SOLUTION FOR ME, AND
AGAIN, NOTHING TO DO WITH
PICKING ON THEM.
IT IS A CONSTRUCTIVE SOLUTION IS
TO TAKE ALL OF THE INVOLUNTARY
FUNDING, I DON’T KNOW HOW MUCH
IT IS.
BUT VOLUNTARY FUNDING, TAKE THE
OTHER AND GIVE IT TO THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE SUFFERING, THE SMALL
BUSINESS, BECAUSE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE BEING HARMED BY CHINA
AND RELATIONSHIP, YOU CAN SUE
CHINA OR YOU CAN TAKE THAT MONEY
AND FUNNEL IT TO AMERICA’S BAR
TAB.
BECAUSE AS THAT IS WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT AS WE NEED TO PAY
AMERICA’S BAR TAB SO THAT THEY
SPEND MORE MONEY.
DOES NOT ASSIGN ANY BLAME, IT
JUST SHIFTS SOME OF THE MONEY
OVER TO THE VICTIMS WHO COULD
REALLY USE IT.
THAT IS MY SOLUTION.
>> Jesse: EMILY, DO YOU LIKE
THE IDEA OF W.H.O. PICKING UP
OUR BAR TAB?
>> Emily: I LIKE THE IDEA OF
ANYONE PICKING UP OUR BAR TAB.
I THINK THAT’S GREAT.
THE QUESTION THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE OTHER
LEADERS ARE FACING RIGHT NOW IS
HOW DO WE COMPEL CHINA EVER TO
PLAY BY THE SAME RULES AS
EVERYBODY ELSE?
THIS IS ONLY ONE EXAMPLE OF LIKE
50 CONCURRENT ELEMENTS RIGHT
NOW.
WHERE THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF
SUBVERSION AND A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY HAS RESULTED IN
GLOBAL NEGATIVE RESULTS.
AND GIVEN THEIR CURRENT ISSUES
WITH ENVIRONMENT AND TRADE AND
WILDLIFE, IT’S NOT AS IF THIS
MIGHT NOT HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE
AGAIN.
SO I THINK MOVING FORWARD, THERE
NEEDS TO BE SOME TYPE OF GLOBAL
CONSENSUS WHERE THERE IS A ZERO
TOLERANCE FOR THEM.
AT LEAST NOW THERE IS SORT OF A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IT.
>> Jesse: YEAH, APPARENTLY
LAST NIGHT PETER NAVARRO ON
MARTHA’S SHOW SAID THAT THE
UNITED NATIONS HAD ABOUT 15
SUB-AGENCIES LIKE THE W.H.O. AND
CHINA, CONTROLLING FIVE OUT OF